When thinking about the life of Bruce Wayne,
many can agree that his most famous life event
is his most tragic.
Most iterations of the Batman story, at some
point, have depicted the event that sealed
his fate: the murder of his parents.
It's a moment that changes the course of his
life forever, driving him to create a symbol
that the criminals of Gotham will fear.
Matt Reeves' "The Batman," unlike so many
previous cinematic incarnations of the character,
does not tread on this familiar territory.
When "The Batman" picks up, it is two years
after Bruce has started wearing the cowl.
He feels the trauma of his past deeply, but
it is represented more in what is not said,
than what is.
"I don't care what happens to me."
Bruce has become reclusive, hiding away in
Wayne Tower with Alfred, played by Andy Serkis,
only venturing out around people when it will
help him solve a mystery.
There are many aspects about this version
of Batman that are heartbreaking.
Bruce's self-imposed isolation, and his inability
to connect to other people in a meaningful
way, are just a couple.
And in the midst of all the murder and mayhem
the film depicts, it is one scene in particular
that shows just how sad the life of Gotham's
Dark Knight truly is.
Throughout the film, Bruce has made it abundantly
clear how alone he is.
He goes out at night and fights as many criminals
as he can.
When he comes home, the only person who tries
to forge a connection with him is Alfred,
but it's a one-sided effort.
"If this continues, it won't be long before
you've nothing left."
Alfred is concerned about Bruce's nighttime
activities and why a serial killer is leaving
him messages.
But for all of Alfred's attempts to take care
of Bruce, the young Wayne pushes him away.
He tells Alfred that he isn't his father and
doesn't accept his guidance.
This dynamic reaches its devastating peak
when the Riddler sends a package to Wayne
Tower.
While it's meant for Bruce, Alfred opens it,
just as a bomb inside is detonated.
Alfred survives the attack, but he is terribly
wounded.
When he regains consciousness in the hospital,
he and Bruce have a loaded conversation, full
of pain and unresolved trauma.
Both Alfred and Bruce have burdens they need
to unload upon one another, and when they
do, it finally brings them together.
When Alfred first wakes up from his injuries,
Bruce is there by his side.
But rather than express sympathy, the Dark
Knight's first response is to accuse his longtime
butler of keeping family secrets from him.
Bruce lashes out, upset that he never knew
his father had a business relationship with
known mobster Carmine Falcone.
However, once the two resolve this issue,
Bruce admits to being afraid for the first
time since the death of his parents.
To cope with the loss, he became a symbol
devoid of any fear.
By becoming the personification of vengeance,
he ensured he would never feel powerless again.
But Bruce acknowledges that when Alfred's
life was in danger, being Batman did not help.
He admits that Alfred is one of the only people
that means something to him anymore, and that
losing him would be just as bad as losing
his parents.
Bruce wasn't the only one who has been holding
onto past pain.
Alfred holds immense guilt over the deaths
of the Waynes.
As he tells his young charge, Bruce was "just
a boy" when they died, and Alfred thinks he
should have done better to protect the Waynes.
Not only that, but he never felt equipped
to take care of a young Bruce or raise him
properly, after being thrust into a parental
role.
Alfred remarks that Bruce needed a father,
and he never felt that he was good enough
to fill that role.
He blames himself for Bruce's emotional withdrawal,
repression, and rejection of the Wayne legacy.
That said, it is clear that Alfred holds no
ill will towards Bruce, despite how cold their
relationship appears earlier in the film.
This scene marks the first time both men have
truly opened up to one another, and it allows
them to finally begin healing their relationship.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.